その女性100m ごとにコーヒーを安く売ってくれる機械が置いてあること
お手洗いの個室に入るときそのトイレに小便がついていないそしてそれが詰まってい
ないと期待できること
マークの店員でも神変に働くこと爪を切っても散らからないこと
財布をマークしても狼狽しなくて良いことすべて
の会話がトランプをめぐるものではないこと満員電車の中でも普通に息が出来ること
これはね植松伸夫さんの世界観チーズをかけなくてもほとんどの食べ物はおいしいこと
国がせ前から育毛剤が切れたときはすぐに頼んだら翌日に届く事危ないと言われている
街でもそれはよるポケモンゴーができるほど安全であること映画化のなかで人が陽日
みたいに呼ばれたりしないこと
友達と
一緒にお風呂に入っても変に思われないことアキラのサウンドトラック
うん連中にちょっとした味噌起こしても周りの人は全員マッドマックスに返信しない
ことへこんだときはみなとみらいに行けること本というものに興味を持っているとかも
たくさんいること
豆柴の濃いね国民が食事と運動の大切さをなめないことなく
顔や白ぞ1500円で抜いてもらえることメイドインジャパンと書かれていれば
商品が長く持つと確信できることこ発
無印の良品を打ってくれる店があることとにかく年配の方が現金の入った封筒を
押し付けてくること
機内で夏を頼んでも ca さんに舌打ちされないことでー三味の利息
なった時もう1本ちゃんと来るのかな心配しなくて良いこと
ココイチ100均で食器を前の買っても誰にもバレないこと
ちょっとだけきわどい冗談を言ってもを公に非難されないこと
まあ今はね
ni